[Música]
américa latina es la más afectada por la
pandemia mientras que brasil y méxico
tienen el mayor número de muertes en la
región en venezuela- médicos y
opositores se piden a la onu que
intervenga para que el gobierno de
nicolás maduro permita el ingreso de
vacunas al país
médicos advierten que la vida de alexéi
navalni corre peligro el opositor ruso
quien se encuentra encarcelado lleva más
de dos semanas en una huelga de hambre y
los galenos aseguran que tiene riesgo de
fallos renales y de paro cardíaco en
cualquier momento naval ni sobrevivió en
2020 a un envenenamiento con el agente
tóxico no acá
y los dos mayores emisores de gases
efecto invernadero eeuu y china se
comprometieron a cooperar en materia de
cambio climático y a reforzar la
implementación del acuerdo de parís esto
de cara a la cumbre virtual sobre el
clima convocada por el presidente joe
biden que se celebrará los próximos
jueves y viernes
una feliz mañana de domingo mi nombre es
ángela gómez y aquí comienzan las
noticias de france 24 un centenar de
trabajadores de la salud se movilizaron
en la capital de venezuela caracas
frente a la sede de naciones unidas para
el desarrollo para pedir al gobierno de
nicolás maduro que permita el ingreso de
vacunas al país después de las
suspensiones de las dosis de astrazéneca
una campaña que estuvo acompañada por
dirigentes políticos y activistas de la
oposición mientras la situación
sanitaria por kobe 19 se agudiza en el
país latinoamericano marina sardenya
amplia
vacunas ya o basta de muertes fueron los
lemas de la protesta de las médicas y
enfermeras venezolanas el sábado unas
150 personas en su mayoría profesionales
médicos salieron a las calles para
exigir al gobierno de nicolás maduro un
plan de vacunación sin sesgo político y
que tenga como prioridad al personal
sanitario el líder de la oposición juan
guaidó lideró la marcha en la capital
caracas
[Música]
por el contrario estamos hoy viendo
juntos
las medidas de seguridad que siempre
por favor aquí
venezuela también está sumida en una
nueva ola de la pandemia saca la nación
comenzó la vacunación el pasado febrero
no hay reportes de cuántas personas han
sido inoculadas con las dosis rusa
sputnik y la china sino pharma que
inicialmente estaban destinadas a los
profesionales de la salud y maestros
pero gremio médico denuncias retrasos no
queremos que la vacuna sea politizada
queremos que la vacuna sea administrada
a toda la población venezolana sin
ningún tipo de exclusión y de control
social
según la ong médicos unidos más de 480
trabajadores sanitarios han fallecido
por el coronavirus pero primero lo que
estamos en la primera línea que somos el
personal de salud estamos en riesgo ya
que muchas veces no tenemos el equipo de
protección personal completo para
atender a nuestros pacientes venezuela
suma más de 180.000 contagios y casi dos
mil decesos unas cifras que muchas
organizaciones consideran que no
muestran la situación real del país
cuyos frágiles hospitales están
saturados y acumulan largas filas para
conseguir oxígeno
también en venezuela- del opositor juan
guaidó sustituyó este sábado a los
cargos no oficiales de una comisión
creada por el mismo en enero de 2020
bajo la aspiración de quitarle al
gobierno de nicolás maduro el control de
la señal del canal multiestatal telesur
wide o señaló que telesur ha sido un
aparato de desinformación y censura el
canal fue fundado en 2005 y cuenta
también con la participación de cuba y
nicaragua por otro lado este viernes el
tribunal supremo de justicia de
venezuela ordenó al diario 'el nacional'
pagar más de 13 millones de dólares al
líder chavista a diosdado cabello como
indemnización por un supuesto daño moral
el rotativo venezolano deberá pagarle
237 mil petros una cripto moneda lanzada
por maduro en 2018 y que está sancionada
por eeuu al valor del cambio del día
equivaldría a la alta suma
los disidentes cubanos denuncian
intimidaciones al margen de las
herméticas sesiones del octavo congreso
del partido comunista raúl castro
renunció a dirigir el partido y en su
discurso aseguró que la oposición en la
isla no tiene liderazgo y que concentra
su activismo en internet mientras que
las calles los parques y las plazas
serán de los revolucionarios marina
sardiña amplia la retirada de raúl
castro al frente del partido comunista
de cuba podría aparecer el fin de una
era pero en la isla marcada por su peor
crisis económica en 30 años hay poca
esperanza de cambio la escasez
generalizada y la falta de libertades
sigue haciendo mella en su población ya
deberían darle paso a nueva mentalidad
creo que
como que se ha enfrascado mucho en la
situación y pienso que por lo menos lo
que son la parte de los artistas la
parte del humano como tal debería tener
un poco más de libertad entonces a lo
mejor con ese cambio pues que vengan
rodeado de un fuerte hermetismo a puerta
cerrada el viernes inicio el quinquenal
congreso del partido único en cuba el
comunista durante cuatro días se debate
el rumbo político del país de la reunión
saldrá también el próximo dirigente de
la institución el escenario es diferente
al de hace cinco años ahora con una
ligera expansión de internet y las redes
sociales donde los activistas artistas y
disidentes han trasladado su mensaje de
protesta este sábado muchos disidentes
cubanos denunciaron intimidaciones
arrestos e interrogatorios los días
antes del congreso y llamaron uno por
uno a los del 27 ene para amenazarlos
con que si salían de sus casas durante
los días del congreso los iban a llevar
presos por un largo periodo de tiempo la
activista es una de las líderes del
movimiento conformado por artistas el
pasado 27 de noviembre se reunieron en
la habana para pedir libertades
y acceso de la represión a los
opositores del gobierno algo que se
antoja todavía lejano pensar que castró
de un paso al lado ya que quien tomará
las riendas del país miguel díaz canel
fue designado por el mismo castro la
familia castro sigue estando en los
principales cargos de poder en cuba
es grave del estado de salud del
opositor ruso alexéi navalni dos semanas
después de iniciar una huelga de hambre
en prisión un grupo de médicos dice que
su visión empeoró y que está cerca de
una falla renal la hija del político de
44 años surgió que se le permita acceso
a atención médica de confianza y sus
seguidores dicen que las autoridades
amenazan con alimentarlo por la fuerza
vamos a moscú nuestro corresponsable
xavier colás tiene detalles
los resultados de las pruebas a las que
han tenido acceso a los familiares de
naval y revelan un nivel muy elevado de
potasio que puede causar un paro
cardíaco hay niveles preocupantes además
de creatinina que indican problemas
renales aleccionaban y fue arrestado el
pasado 17 de enero a su regreso a rusia
desde alemania es el principal opositor
al kremlin y se encuentra en su tercera
semana de huelga de hambre un médico del
líder opositor ruso asegura que su salud
se está deteriorando rápidamente naval y
de 44 años podría hallarse al borde de
la muerte
el opositor inició la huelga de hambre
en protesta por no permitirse la visita
de sus médicos cuando empezó a sufrir
dolores fuertes en la espalda y además
dijo que tenía entumecida una de sus
piernas el servicio penitenciario
estatal ruso asegura que nava ni está
recibiendo toda la atención médica
necesaria sus médicos personales sin
embargo no han conseguido que se
autorice su entrada en prisión para
examinarlo y sus seguidores exigen su
puesta en libertad
tras una visita de dos días a china el
enviado especial para el cambio
climático de eeuu john kerry y su
homólogo chino xie zhenhua se
comprometieron a reforzar la
implementación del acuerdo de parís
contra la crisis climática en shanghai
se alcanzó el entendimiento confirmado
por el ministerio de medioambiente chino
y por el cual ambas naciones deberían
aumentar sus acciones individuales
contra el cambio climático entre tanto
kerry se trasladó a corea del sur que ha
expresado su preocupación por la
decisión de japón de liberar al mar un
millón de toneladas de agua contaminada
de la planta nuclear de fukushima
kerry defendió las acciones limón así
dijo que el plan de vertimiento era
transparente
estados unidos y china- trabajarán
juntos para atender la crisis climática
es la primera vez que china se ha unido
diciendo que se trata de una crisis
y en roma italia cientos de personas que
trabajan en la industria del
entretenimiento y la hospitalidad de
protestaron pidiendo ayuda al gobierno
mientras el país se prepara para reabrir
golpeando baúles negros los vacíos
utilizados en conciertos y en teatros
los trabajadores se reunieron en la
plaza del popolo de la capital para
dramatizar su demanda de un fondo
gubernamental para ayudarlos a
sobrevivir a partir del 26 de abril en
las zonas que sean catalogadas amarillas
y blancas con niveles de infección bajos
los restaurantes y los bares podrán
atender a los clientes en las mesas
exteriores y los cines y teatros
reabrirán con límites de asistencia
y un rápido repaso por nuestro sitio web
e france24 puntocom en la portada
ustedes pueden encontrar la información
sobre kobe 19 hoy el mundo después de
superar los 3 millones de decesos por el
virus y reino unido- se despidió del
duque de edimburgo desde la capilla de
san jorge' de windsor esta y otras
noticias las podrán profundizar aquí en
nuestro sitio web
siga con nosotros volvemos en minutos en
france 24
[Música]